hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff uh we are continuing
our uh match between well not continuing
starting our match uh between paul
charles murphy and
henry edward bird as we mentioned uh in
the
previous video of the morphe saga henry
bird
into town and will now take on paul
morphy and i know what you guys are
thinking
how many staunton's minions must murphy
defeat before he actually faces the
final boss
uh well imagine how morphy felt uh you
know you're enjoying this match from the
comfort of your own home and morphe had
to travel all the way to england
to face them and uh well of course uh
staunton in the end
and here i will just uh read you a very
very short part from
uh from from the book on morphe i can't
remember
who the author is uh due to the
anesthesia but i will put it
in the description below uh so while
morphe awaited a reply to his letter of
august 14th
henry edward byrd one of england's
strongest players returns to london
and the result of his encounter with
morphy was the most dramatic so this is
what he says in the book
and we're not going to spoil anything by
telling you what the result was
why the match was dramatic but it was
and also something that uh
you know very interesting uh about henry
bird on
his uh wikipedia page it says although
bird was a practicing accountant not a
professional chess player
it has been said that he lived for chess
and would play
anybody anywhere anytime under any
conditions and at the time
uh this game was played he was not as
old as in the photo here
he was actually 29 years of age so uh
that being said
let's check out the game and this is the
first game of their match
or it might not be the first one because
we don't have all the games
from their match uh on record on only a
few of them but
we'll get back to that so morphe has the
white pieces in this game and he opens
with e4
sorry about that uh and uh for those of
you who are wondering why
my hair is you know going places uh uh
well the place where i usually cut my
hair it
has been closed because of you know the
thing that shall not be named on youtube
so i had to find another one and you
know
i did find it but it will only happen
tomorrow
so e4 and bird replies with e5 and
morphe of course
goes ahead and launches the f-pawn so
the king's gambit is on the board
and uh with the white pieces he wants to
see what what bird can do
so here we have bishop the c5 bird
declines the king's gambit and he goes
for rapid development with bishop to c5
which is fine
with knight to f3 and d6 now we have c3
by morphe
saying that okay even if you capture it
now i have a massive center here
after d4 and even if you don't capture
i'm still going to play d4 uh at some
point so here bishop to g4
pinning the pinning the knight so now uh
the knight is not really
uh engaged in any uh you know struggle
for the central squares and here
bishop the c4 and already morphy has a
very nice threat for example if you're
not careful for example if you go for
something like knight to f6
you immediately go f captures on e5 and
the black will not be able to capture
black will have to give up the light
square bishop
uh because if you capture then it's the
very simple trick bishop captures and f7
captures the knight captures on e5 with
check with a double attack on the bishop
on g4 you'd have to move the king and
ninja snipe picks up the bishop
and the white is white is practically
winning if no funny business occurs
so here after bishop to c4 we have
knight to c6 this prevents the idea that
we've just shown because the
e5 pawn is defended twice by the pawn
and by the knight here
so here uh we have b4 the so-called uh
almost delayed king simon's gambit uh
but
both of them are are declined uh
it's not actually called that i just
call it that you know when the f and b
pawn are played
if you guys want you can also call it
that you know it's totally cool
so here bishop back to b6 and now a4
preparing a5 to trap the bishop so of
course a6 bird
makes some room for the bishop and now
h3 by morphe
and here we have already a very exciting
moment uh something that happens when
black does not accept the gambit white
really
extends with the pawns and it's not a
problem but here you have to decide
whether you want to capture the knight
or you want to go back with the bishop
so it's an it's an open game it can very
easily open up so maybe
maybe keeping the bishop pair make sense
however
bird goes for bishop captures and f3 he
has a different idea queen captures
morphy brings the queen into the game
still unable to castle as the bishop
slices through this diagonal and now
knight to f6 bird is now also ready at
the castle
we have d3 by morphe now preparing to
bring the bishop into the game the
knight can also join the game maybe
maybe go to e3 maybe to g3 all depends
on what black plays
and the queen to e7 albert says i might
castle kingside but i also might castle
queenside although it's
uh a bit less likely that i'm gonna
castle queenside with all of these pawns
here
so here we have f5 uh morphe now closes
the
uh the the structure and it's not going
to be easy to make a breakthrough if
anyone's going to be making a
breakthrough probably going to be black
with
with d5 and here while you could castle
here
it's uh well it's a bit dangerous bishop
to g5 is coming and it's just going to
be
very unpleasant after bishop g5 you can
bring the knight into the game
for example to h5 with a double attack
on the knight and it doesn't seem like
black can do all that much here
so here bird instead goes rook to d8 and
now comes
bishop to g5 but now it's a little bit
different as uh
the the king still hasn't castled or you
know
the blacking might not castle at all and
knight back to b8
this allows knight to d7 to add another
defender to the knight and also you are
preparing a central breakthrough with c6
and
d5 we have knight to d2 morphe continues
to develop
and c6 now by bird we have knight to f1
and now comes d5 so here well
there are a couple of ways you could
treat this position for example
a5 is always welcome knight bd7 always
welcome a bird wastes no time and he
strikes in the center with d5
and it's a very interesting idea because
you can actually capture on d5 for
example he captures on d5 you run into
e4 and it looks very
uh very scary i don't think morphy had
any
trouble calculating this out but as you
know morphe was
lazy and calculating when there was no
need to do that
something that he shares with for
example jose royal capoblanca
uh but uh here we could see a trade for
example uh if queen captures on e4
uh very interesting because the knight
is spin knight captures bishop captures
and now bishop to f2 with check tricking
white a little bit but not all that much
king e2 knight captures on c3 with check
captures and now you can capture on e7
and we end this
uh variation with white being up upon
it's not much but uh
all in all white should be better uh so
instead
uh of going for something like this
morphe goes bishop back to b3 he wants
to keep
everything on the board and now comes
queen to d6
here again a lot of moves are possible
the instant these
d4 is possible a5 is always an idea
because you you really want to put
pressure on that
over extended the queen side upon
majority uh but okay
queen to d6 and now comes knight the g3
by morphe and again uh a lot of very
interesting options for bird again
a5 always an idea putting pressure here
just developing knight bd7 adding more
uh well more just more defense to this
knight on f6
so these are all possibilities however
uh bird castles here and
uh it could be a little bit dangerous
because morphy immediately goes knight
to h5
and now what's uh what's morphy's idea
here
well his idea is that of course if the
knight is captured then uh morphy will
grab the rook on d8
but this is exactly what what can be
played because after captures captures
and captures
yes the queen recaptures but now d4 is
incredibly strong for black and it's not
going to be all that easy for white to
mount the attack the f7 pawn is nicely
covered
and the white has to figure out some way
of bringing the rooks into the game you
can
of course charge with the g4 g5 but
black is also very
very quick in uh in the attack and the
knight can easily come and help out
with the defense so uh it it is possible
however
uh after this uh story about so many
however
after knight to h5 uh bird first played
d captures on e4 he threw in
a nice tuition fugue uh but
uh this doesn't actually help him
because after d captures on e4 by morphe
he played knight captures on h5 now
but now it doesn't uh work all that
great
but you're going to tell me why it
doesn't work so feel free to pause the
video here
and find the best move for morphe while
i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it uh congratulations on not grabbing
the knight right away and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
uh
rook to d1 rook to d1 is the move
because if you go for the
knight right away then queen to d3 is
really
a nuisance uh because you're threatening
e for your threatening
c3 uh you don't allow this capture
because then you lose control of the d2
square for example if bishop captures
rook captures
there's just no no defending this if
queen f3 defending
just queen d to check king f1 and now
rook to d3 and it's all over
ah the the queen doesn't really have
anywhere to go you have to guard the f2
square because of checkmate
and if you block for example with this
then it's just queen f4
check the king has nowhere to go king k1
and rookie 3 just wins on the spot
and another thing after if you capture
an h5 queen to d3 you could go queen f3
seems like you're defending everything
but then it's just rook to d7 and
the game continues so it is possible to
capture the knight although you don't
really gain anything
with proper play so here morphy played
rook to d1
and now it means problems for uh for
bird because after the queen moves uh
the rook
will be attacked twice and this is uh
this is a problem morphe will
win material here we have queen to c7
and now
bishop captures on the e8 we have rook
captures rook captures and queen
captures and it doesn't seem like it's
all that big of a deal
of course uh captures on h5 but
it is it is a lot a morphe king is still
in the center of the board still unable
to castle so this is what
bird is hoping that will allow him to
to achieve something but he still has to
figure out a way of bringing the queen
into the game and also how to bring the
uh knight into the game so here we have
bishop to e3
uh preparing this uh very sneaky
checkmate queen d2 check followed by
queen to f2 checkmate
and now while morphy could capture on f7
not
not with the queen the queen will be
needed uh to guard the checkmate
uh instead he just goes back again
probably lazy to calculate stuff he just
goes back says i'm not material
uh if you want we can trade queens so of
course bird doesn't want to trade queens
and he goes queen to h4 check and it's
very interesting how morphy allows this
uh
king walk uh but it's not all that
difficult to calculate
king e2 of course only playable move
that allows the whites to keep the
advantage
and now uh even queen of teacher king d3
doesn't do anything for black because
there's no way of continuing the attack
the queen cannot deliver any checks
bishop can't deliver checks if knight d7
uh these squares are covered so the
knight cannot join the attack so here
instead after king to e2 we have bishop
back to b6
now clear clearing some squares here for
the queen
but morphy just continues the the king
march king to d2
and now uh bert brings the knight into
the game knight to d7 but now queen g4
morphy says all right uh we either trade
now or you have to play a passive move
uh and of course if you trade morphy
just up material so he's going to beat
you so queen to f2 was played
now hoping for some uh checking
opportunities however uh the game is now
completely lost for black
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for morphe while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations especially if you
also got the first one correct
it is f6 for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show
and uh it's such a strong move because
it threatens
checkmate and also threatens the night
here and there's nothing uh you can do
here
like you could try checking uh queen to
e3 chuck but after king to c2 it
doesn't work you can do one more check
uh queen to
f2 with czech but then king b1 and
there's just
no no continuing this you could capture
the pawn with the queen but you give up
the knight
but it's something you could have done
right away you didn't have to go for all
of these checks so after f6 you could
also
capture with the queen and then give up
the knight and now you're just down a
whole rook it doesn't really make sense
to continue this
so what you could do after this f6 move
to prevent
checkmate is capture with the knight but
this doesn't actually prevent checkmate
you know it only prolongs the game
for three more moves because after queen
to c8 check
it's game over you have to give up the
two remaining pieces uh
or you know i'm just doing this for fun
you could also just give up one and get
checkmated uh but it would end in
checkmate either way
so after this f6 move uh morphe wins the
game
and uh what a victory for morphe
especially i i really enjoyed that
morphy
won the game with f6 being the finishing
move as
he has that you know uh uh you know uh
thorn in his eye when mr barnes played
f6
and that did not go well for morphy uh
but yeah
this is the first game we're showing
from the match uh paul charles morphe
versus henry edward bird
i i do hope you guys enjoyed it and the
other games will also be very enjoyable
now i still don't know if the
all of the games that were played were
lost or maybe they just decided to save
these ones as
these are uh the more enjoyable ones but
if i uh you know discover any clues
about this while i'm reading the book
i will also share this with you so uh
that's uh the game i do hope you enjoyed
it
uh i would like to thank bjorn brenner
harry berglund
ralph wade thomas connors and johan
clayson for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will
uh see you soon continuing the coverage
of the of the good stuff checking up on
your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day